hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book one of
his work on free choice of the will in
the dialog with his student Augustine
sets out what he calls the due or proper
ordering of a human being and what he
means there is is considering the human
being as you might say a complex of
different powers or faculties how is it
that these ought to be arranged in
relation to each other or if you want to
look at it another way which of them
should be ruling or determining what a
person is doing through the agency of
the will now Augustine thinks that there
is something that he calls the eternal
law and part of this includes a certain
structuring of not just human beings but
also what we would view is as lower
beings less developed beings beings that
are lacking in rationality or perhaps
even in sentience and so Augustine sort
of reconstructs with his student how it
is that you know all these these levels
to human being are built upon each other
and he also takes a few little you could
say excursions in
to discussion of the relation between
some of them that are particularly
important and I do want to signal that
right off the bat before we jump into
looking at these different levels
because his framing of it works along
these lines he says that there is a law
in eternal law by which it is just that
everything should have its due order and
he says you know this applies to
governments and temporal laws and
Nations and then he says well what about
human beings does this apply to us and
then he says tell me are you absolutely
certain that you're alive to a student
and the student says yeah of course I am
there's nothing more certain that I know
of and then he says can you distinguish
between living and knowing that you live
can you make this distinction there's
the fact that you're alive and the
processes of living and then there's you
knowing that you're alive and it doesn't
have to be some sort of great you know
systemic worked out knowledge it can
just be I know that I'm alive I'm self
conscious of the fact that I not only am
conscious but that I live and so he goes
on and he he talks about the difference
between us and animals but then he gets
to another point a little bit later on
so he says animals live and as we now
see they live without reason and he says
so now you see that you know what you
said you did not know not everything
which lives knows that it's lit that it
lives though everything which knows that
it lived necessarily lives and so the
student says yeah that's right so then
he asked well which of these is better
which of these is more excellent and the
student says to know that we live now
here's where it gets really interesting
Augustine then says do you think that to
know that we live is better than life
itself
and you might say whoa that's you know
how are you going to do that if you're
not alive right knowing that you're
alive is basically predicated on the
assumption that you are living he's not
saying oh well let's strip away life
from you and
compare them side-by-side because
there's something else going on here he
says do you perhaps understand that
knowledge is a higher and purer form of
life since no one can know unless he has
understanding what else is understanding
and here's a beautiful phrase here then
a life brighter and more perfect through
the very life of the mind so this is a
really important little passage here
because what it clarifies for us is that
as we move from these lower levels that
we share in common with animals and
plants up into these these higher levels
we're not talking about functions that
are totally separated off as if there's
these you know hermetically sealed off
containers or something like that
instead you have and this is a very
common notion in ancient philosophy you
find it among the Platonic and then
later Neoplatonic and also among the
stoic philosophers there are these
degrees of being and as you move up the
degrees of being these are differences
in an intensity that sort of build off
of each other so that's an important
consideration another important
consideration that he brings up too and
he's talking about knowledge and he says
you fully grasped and explained my own
view provided that knowledge can never
be evil and then Augustine says yes I
think knowledge cannot be evil unless we
give the word a new meaning and use
knowledge for practical experience
practical experience you know we say we
have knowledge but that that actually
can be bad in some respects he gives an
example of being punished but we might
also think it's about the practical
experiences about doing things that
we're not supposed to do and getting
away with them right how to do that so
then there's this long discussion about
what it is that we human beings have in
common with other things and what we
don't so
he says whatever it is by which human
beings are superior to beasts whether
mind or spirit or whether either of them
as the correct term because we find both
in Sacred Scripture
if this governs and controls all the
other elements of which the human being
is composed then the human being is duly
ordered so when the top part mind or
spirit or reason is running the show
then we have proper order within our
souls and we are following the eternal
law which is guiding us towards towards
that right so how could we how could we
go wrong so he says think about what it
is that we have in common with other
things plants animals humans all share
in nourishment they consume something
right plants don't go around and you
know shovel food or anything like that
there are a few carnivorous plants of
course you know like the Venus flytrap
but for the most part they're consuming
things in a much more sedate manner
growth that's something central to
plants and to animals generation that is
reproduction if you're suffering from
you know allergies it could be because
there's so much pollen in the air and
pollen is basically one way in which
plants are gonna reproduce bite down on
you know fruit and you've got seeds in
your mouth and you're like I don't like
these well that's that's how the plant
reproduces itself and then the function
of Health a sort of you know overall
organic whatever we want to call it good
state of the creature those that we
share in common then at the level of
animals we have sense perception and
he's talking about you know what it is
that we might be better or worse than
but we all share in some sort of sense
perception
he says beasts have sight hearing smell
taste touch off and more keenly than we
do we also have movement he talks about
strength vigor muscular power Swift and
easy movement of the body will just
consolidate all that into movement and
the capacity for it and then seeking
bodily pleasure and avoiding bodily pain
says we have this all in common with
beasts with the non-rational animals now
some thinkers in the past would say what
makes us good is what we don't have in
common with the the animals the higher
part of our self Augustine actually
subdivides that he says not all of how
we differ from the animals is
necessarily good by itself it has to be
again in proper order so what does he
bring up very interestingly he says that
there are some other things that we have
that beasts don't seem to share but
which are not the highest qualities of a
human being
laughing and joking our sense of humor
you know that's fun but it's not the
highest part of ourselves
he also says there's love of praise and
glory and ambition although the beasts
don't have these passions we must
suppose that we're better than the
beasts because we have them why because
when this creating is not subject to
reason it actually makes us miserable or
wretched so you know we're different
than the animals in that for example I
mean you could say animals have social
hierarchies but animals don't pride
themselves on how much money they have
in the bank or other you know quite
arbitrary signs of their social
hierarchies it tends to be based on
things a little bit closer to their
bodily nature than the you know crazy
stuff that looking at it from a
perspective of reason the crazy stuff
that we think actually matters so much
so what what is the upshot here well if
we're going to be properly ordered that
is in accordance with the eternal law
the highest should rule the the lower
not the reverse so we shouldn't simply
be driven by our desire for bodily
pleasure or avoiding bodily pain if we
make that the central priority and we
only use our reason or mind or knowledge
to try to do that we're actually not
just going to end up with
wrong consequences in actions we're
screwing ourselves up we're subverting
the proper ordering of things
likewise if our whole life is spent just
about you know laughing and joking and
you might say oh what about those poor
comedians well you know it's possible to
be a comedy writer and not to make
comedy the only thing in your life that
you're always looking for a laugh you
might have productive human
relationships with other people and
value some things comedy can actually be
used as a great tool as it is in many
great comics for hire things you know
love of praise glory your social status
all that sort of stuff that could also
drive people to make the wrong sort of
decisions using their Faculty of reason
or mind or whatever we're going to call
it just to try to attain those ends or
it could be a combination of these sorts
of things the point is unless reason is
running the show and then ordering all
these other things in turn you're going
to have some some real problems and that
is going to be not only a product of the
free choice of the will it's also going
to condition the later decisions of the
will because it's going to introduce all
sorts of vicious dispositions and a
person is not going to be very well off
indeed with respect to them he actually
talks about this a little bit later he
says that the punishment is the mind
being ruled by passion being robbed of
its store of virtue being dragged here
and there
poor and needy now judging false for
true now defending now attacking what
before it approved running off in a
fresh falsehood all sorts of other
things this is the passions rage like
tyrants and throw into confusion the
whole soul and life of men with storms
from every quarter it doesn't
necessarily have to be quite so dramatic
as that one could just be you know
devoted to a life of pleasure seeking
and unable to see anything outside of
that sphere and missing out on a whole
lot of what makes us distinctively human
as a result or driven by ambition all
the time and
constantly getting into conflicts with
people which are not going to be
particularly productive and are going to
again sort of truncate the life of the
soul so this is what Augustine calls the
right ordering between the different
parts or functions of the human being
when they're all aligned properly when
reason or or you know mind or spirit is
running the show in accordance with
wisdom or knowledge then everything goes
as it ought to otherwise what you've got
is essentially the human being as
damaged goods
you